[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the suicide of a presidency
occurred on Friday February 17 2017 at
4:32 p.m. Eastern Time the fake news
media failing New York Times CNN NBC
News and many more is not my enemy it is
the enemy of the American people
SiC Donald Trump struck a fatal blow
against his own presidency at that
moment with the use of those terms never
heard before from an American president
not even from Richard Nixon not ever the
presidency of course did not end with
those words but the inevitability that
it will end later or sooner the truth
that his position as president is no
longer tenable became fixed the moment
he pressed send and promulgated those
evil words and then he deleted them but
he deleted them not because they were
the spasmodic outburst of a man with no
self-control suddenly understanding that
he had just finally thrown everything he
had achieved out the window and he was
seeking to destroy the record as Nixon
destroyed his tapes no he deleted them
because he had left out some of the
specific targets he wanted to smear with
words that even the evil founder of the
Soviet state Vladimir Lenin waited until
he was a month in power before using 16
minutes later the fake news media
failing New York Times NBC News ABC CBS
CNN is not my enemy it is the enemy of
the American people
there is no walking those words back and
as seen in the White House daily press
briefing Tuesday afternoon Trump isn't
even going to try to do that because
he's a fool a man holding the office of
the President of the United States using
the language of the totalitarian Soviet
states the language used to mark groups
of people for removal and death a man
holding the Office of the President of
the United States specifically attacking
a group specifically protected by the
Bill of Rights the First Amendment's
ever passed to the Constitution to which
he swore allegiance apparently falsely
swore allegiance but a month earlier
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof
or abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press or the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances freedom the press sandwich in
among the freedom from a state religion
or against government of Bridgman of
free speech or of the right of assembly
or a petition against grievances an
attack on freedom of the press is an
attack on all those other freedoms and
all those Americans who exercise all
those other freedoms it is an attack on
the Constitution itself and that may not
mean much to Trump or his Wilder
supporters nor even to some of the men
and women on the fringes of Congress to
whom democracy has always been nothing
more than a brand name but the most
tepid of Democrats must realize or be
made to realize that everybody else in
the president's party now has to decide
how to answer these new questions
speaker Ryan do you agree or the New
York Times NBC News ABC CBS CNN and many
more the enemy of the American people
vice president pence a decade ago you
co-sponsored a bill to let reporters
protect confidential sources do you
agree with the president or do you
believe in freedom of the press Majority
Leader McConnell can you defend the
President of the United States calling
Americans holding American jobs in
American owned businesses the enemies of
the American people
Senator McCain do you believe the
president should be calling any American
citizens a phrase made infamous by the
Communist Lenin Secretary of Defense
mattis when people say that freedom of
speech and freedom of the press exists
because of the United States military
and that the military fights for free
speech and for freedom of the press what
exactly does that mean
judge Neal Gorsuch do you believe in the
First Amendment to the Constitution of
the United States Republican candidate
for the Senate for the house of the
state legislature for village mayor for
the school board not condemning Donald
Trump means not condemning his belief
that the news media is the enemy of the
American people do you support Donald
Trump or do you think the news media is
the enemy of the
American people these questions and
similarly blunt follow-ups again and
again and again this is a door Trump has
closed behind himself forever he cannot
reopen it and go back through even if he
were smart enough to try to do so it is
the suicide of a presidency because
whether all those Republicans answer
those questions now or next fall they
will answer them and they will not be
able to nuance their answers and if the
country still believes in democracy and
not fascism it will punish any
politician who does not repudiate
Trump's authoritarian madness this does
not mean his presidency ends today or
tomorrow Richard Nixon committed the
suicide of a presidency in the late
morning of Friday June 23 1972 when he
ordered the FBI to discontinue its
investigation of the Watergate break-in
of just six days earlier but the tape
recording of his order did not become
public until August 5th 1974 Nixon's
presidency died of its two-year-old
self-inflicted wounds at noon on August
9th 1974 just as Trump's presidency will
die of the wound he inflicted on it and
for exactly the same reason not because
it was a crime against the United States
of America and our Constitution but
because Republicans were going to have
to answer questions about it in the
midterm elections as the Republicans of
1974 would have had no choice but to run
against Richard Nixon the Republicans of
our day will have no choice but to run
against Donald Trump we've always been
very celestial about our motives in this
country the Constitution the flag
American exceptionalism but ultimately
most of our internal decisions have come
down to far less lofty issues often
they've come right down into the gutters
and the sewers of who is going to be
reelected and who is not and on Twitter
on February 17th Donald Trump guaranteed
that Republicans would have to try to
get themselves reelected as Republicans
while a Republican president insisted
the Free Press was an enemy of the
American people those Republicans can't
do that so they will not try that so
Trump will have to go
and so his prayer
as he is right now dying by his own hand
the only question is how fast will it
die resist peace